the incredibly sexy Sofia Vergara is
gonna be out in just a minute or two and
I've noticed this before whenever we
have a beautiful woman on the show
suddenly a lot more crew guys are
hanging around I know exactly what
you're talking just lurking all around
like creeps waiting to catch a glimpse
of Sofia Vergara they don't think I
noticed but I do now all right I mean
these are guys that don't need to be
here for example we don't usually have
two guys operating one camera you know
Susie a one-man job and most days we
don't have a second cue card guy with
the script in Bulgarian and usually the
band's piano tuner is gone by now we
don't have him around for this show that
was so an electronic keyboard exactly
try it Andy and we don't eat a courtroom
sketch artist today why is this guy even
here and I've never seen that human
applause sign before we don't need that
guy
and why why does our show suddenly need
a Potter I mean it just seems that and
then why do we need another guy to
recreate the pottery scene from the
movie go that one is I feel like we do
new again again we do need that now we
have a lot of cameras in the studio so I
don't know why we need a street luge
point of view cameras
[Applause]
we really don't usually have a scuba
diver on set now we don't I have no idea
what we have a Steve Harvey impersonator
tonight every show needs a Steve Harvey
impersonator play oh I know they ain't
no no see we're Viva let's play oh yeah
we got a lot of studio tours it comes
through here but I don't recognize this
tour company I don't know why they're
here today
and finally finally we usually don't
have a bell ringer at the show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
take a baby we come back Sofia Vergara
is gonna be here yeah
you
you